yummy who do I know compare myself to
you maybe you see it you heard of
Iverson you know take that time six so
technically I'll be about ten of them
you know I'm saying hey what you [ __ ] if
you goddamn gonna [ __ ] it get it we wish
to build a [ __ ] I'll get it from head
to toe everything now everything that's
right check this out
Jersey black-and-white shooter sleep
black and white shirt black and white
[ __ ] Penda peg black and white check
this [ __ ] out is anything up in here nah
man guess what holds tell black and
white the [ __ ] - you don't need Jordans
[ __ ] alright you need stop baby
homie I grew up in the suburbian ghetto
homie you know I'm saying we got one
Walmart in a target that they be
battling each other all the time in but
I'll be going to the Walmart because I'm
down like that you know I'm saying he's
not even real [ __ ] dude they got all the
kids that they got clean floors
you know people be gonna do customer
service and [ __ ] like that what's up
with that and you know she be backing up
on me with his big-ass African bush hey
that's right [ __ ]
I'm amphibious means I could use both my
arms
I'm ambidextrous yeah that's chemistry
[ __ ] I've been stabbed 14 times in my
left foot that's it
70 times on my back three times in my
eye but I can still see I got vision
homie I'm trippin like homie over here
just being a little [ __ ] and stuff like
there was a bald ass little head and
like you never missed em everybody been
stabbed
alright my mom is dead 17 times she be
trippin you mean she have 14 kids what
you know I'm just saying what daddy's
office job this is true what poop
carries the screwdriver in their shoe
and stab somebody when you're going up
for late I know you learned how to play
basketball in some kind of North Koreans
forget internment camp [ __ ] okay I
should call the cops but you know I
don't snitch cuz I had a t-shirt stop
snitching I'm not hypocrite or Pleasants
black man [ __ ] it's coming with let's
play the best attention to details he's
gonna be a superstar like that I liked
it what Sally knew the old days of
course Colin Beavan hookers and crack
open those black you play tennis don't
get that on film
grab this [ __ ] I was hanging on top of
the line no no no cut out there shut up
[ __ ] that's unprofessional with you and
stuff like that he wants talk about
scamming people ain't about real
basketball did you see his basketball
they got the real color on it see when
you got to play ball your balls got to
be ashy you know he ain't even a real
basketball player you know why did you
check out his ball he got the real color
on any [ __ ] like that you if you ballin
like your ball got to be ashy no I'm
saying we got lucky a lot I say this
life
you filming one - I would have to get
around you your thighs that's nothing
I've been dangerous I'm talking them
stop it
allocating [ __ ] I'll just let me black
jiggle often follows how we get back
we'll get some dip - one two one two
three oh there we go backwards back
Digga Digga Digga okay ready yeah
Oh
I'm scared boom shadow be a bit push off
of me I'm wet give you a little extra
lift final season yeah wait you got it
you got it like warms up one two no no I
can't do this